nachdem ich letztens jeden Zug bis zur
Endstation genommen habe und dabei nur
in eine Richtung gefahren bin meintet
ihr dass es mehr Sinn machen würde wenn
ich immer am Gleis auf den nächsten Zug
warte das habe ich umgesetzt und zwar so
lange bis ich an einem Gleis ankomme an
dem an dem Tag kein Zug mehr fährt viel
Spaß und damit einen wunderschönen guten
Morgen Leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich bin in meinem Büro
Bahnhof ist nicht weit wir Steppen jetzt
los und heute wird ein sehr
anstrengender langer aber auch
spannender Tag und ich bin mal gespannt
wie weit es mich bringt und wo ich am
Ende Lande we ich habe das ja beim
letzten Mal nicht ohne Grund so gemacht
wie ich es gemacht habe jetzt besteht
halt die Möglichkeit dass ich gar nicht
weit komme sondern die ganze Zeit nur in
irgendwelche Richtungen hin und her
fahre vielleicht mal in Hannover bin
dann irgendwo wieder im Ruhrgebiet keine
Ahnung wobei ihr meintet ja das wird
klappen also let's go so Leute ich bin
unterwegs zum Bahnhof hab mir noch was
zu trinken und zu essen geholt ich habe
natürlich eure Kommentare gelesen beim
letzten Video das habe ich auch ungefähr
hier gestartet falls ihr euch erinnern
können dass ich mir doch ein Interrail
Ticket holen soll oder es gibt jetzt
auch wieder das 49 € Deutschland Ticket
glaube ich ich habe mir gar kein Ticket
vorweggeholt wir werden einfach die Züge
mal so buchen und am Ende schauen wie
teuer wird das denn eigentlich wenn ich
den ganzen Tag hier Zug fahre einziger
Vorteil ich habe eine bahnkart 50 so
jetzt aber schnell in Bahnhof und in
ersten Zug der jetzt kommt macht ja Sinn
ich bin auch auf keinem gleich einfach
den ersten Zug der kommt so sieht
übrigens mein Heimatbahnhof von innen
aus wunderschön ich hab geschaut der
erste Zug Wirt jetzt hier Richtung
Bielefeld da muss ich rein oh er kommt
auch
schon das ist der
[Musik]
rb69
so Leute hier könnt ihr sehen ich bin
angekommen ang Gleis 2 und ich fahre auf
jeden Fall immer von Bielefeld nach
Berlin eigentlich fährt von Gleis 2 oder
Gleis 1 meistens ICE ich meine sogar es
ist eigentlich immer Gleis 2 und jetzt
schauen wir mal hier auf der
Anzeigetafel steht schon mal gar nichts
ah da steht ICE 545 nach Berlin ostbahnu
Zug fällt heute aus jawoh dann geht's
weiter um 11 Uhr nach Minden aber wir
haben ja auch gesagt dass wir von
gegenüberliegenden Gleis fahren dürfen
alten Bacon na ja okay dann wird's
wahrscheinlich der weil der ist als
nächstes 10:49 Uhr ne versteht man ja
Gleis 2 gleis 1 ist dann ein Bahnsteig
kann ich dann beides nehmen weil sonst
warte ich glaube ich manchmal einfach
viel zu lange auf den nächsten Zug wenn
ich FCH hab also der fernfkehr in
Richtung Hannover und Berlin ist
komplett geschwert weil da irgendwie ein
Feuerwehreinsatz ist deswegen Pimmel ich
jetzt denke ich auf jeden Fall die
nächsten 2 D Stunden mindestens noch in
so Regionalzügen rum ich könn mir auch
nichts Schöneres vorstellen
wahrscheinlich werde ich wenn es so
keine Ahnung Mittag ist gerade mal 50
oder 60 km von meinem Heimatdorf weg
sein bin gespannt alten
bekel falls i mein Kanal noch nicht
abonniert hab macht das gerne weil in
Zukunft kommen wirklich richtig nice
Videos her Z ich bitte um verständn ich
glaub ich chill mindestens 3 Stunden in
irgendeinem Zug und wir stehen einfach
auf der Stelle wegen irgendeiner
[Musik]
Sperrung so Leute angekommen alten Bacon
ich bin jetzt ungefähr so Luftlinie 55
km glaube ich von meinem Heimatdorf
Heimatort entfernt und wir befinden uns
jetzt hier in Gleis 1 ich habe aber noch
keine Ahnung wie es weitergt mal gucken
welcher Zug als nächstes kommt aber ich
warte jetzt auf jeden Fall einfach hier
mal gucken so Leute weiter geht's jetzt
nach Götting holzminn 12:7 Uhr drüber
steht eine zugentleisung beeinträchtigt
den Zugverkehr also irgendwo ist ein
zugentgleist also an jedem Bahnhof ist
irgendwas passiert gefühlt nächster Stop
wird also Götting sein das ist gar nicht
mal so nah mehr also Götting ist schon
ein Stück ich glaube da bin ich jetzt
ziemlich lange
unterwegs
jetzt muss ich mir hier gerade so ein
Ticket ziehen aus dem Automaten weil ich
das Online nicht buchen konnte 16,95 €
nach Göttingen da werde ich um 14 Uhr
irgendwas
[Musik]
ankommen
ug okay Leute angekommen in Göttingen
bin jetzt hier auf Gleis 5 das war mein
Zug ich hatte irgendwie eine halbe
Stunde Verspätung also ich war da jetzt
fast zweieinhalb Stunden drin wirklich
ich habe mich auch zwei Stunden davon
gefragt was mache ich hier eigentlich
heute wieder für eine Scheiße na ja auf
jeden Fall haben wir hier jetzt gleich 5
daneben ist dann gleich 6 und mal gucken
wo der nächste zukommt ich glaube ich
bin jetzt tatsächlich in diesem System
drin ich weiß nicht genau wie es ist ich
kenne mich jetzt auch nicht so aus aber
das bestimmte Gleise halt nur von
Nahverkehrszügen benutzt werden und die
ICE ist die über göting fahren weil
Götting ist ja auch ein größerer Bahnhof
eher so da hinten stehen weil da hinten
stehen Hal dies aber wir haben ja gesagt
wir bleiben immer auf dem Gleis und ja
mal gucken wo als nächstes hingeht auf
dem Gleis wo ich angekommen bin fuhr um
15:14 Uhr ein RB nach Kassel wir hatten
allerdings erst 14:20 Uhr und am
Nachbargleis stand dann schon bereit ein
weiterer RB der in die Weltmetropole
Einbeck Mitte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fuhr ja super also ich bin jetzt in
einck Mitte hier gibt's ein Gleis und es
sieht aus als wäre ich eigentlich
gestrandet also ich will ja nichts sagen
Leute aber hätte ich mir vorher wieder
eine Richtung ausgesucht dann wäre ich
jetzt sicherlich vielleicht schon in
einem anderen Land oder zumindest 5 oder
600 km von meinem Heimatdorf Weg
stattdessen bin ich irgendwo in
Niedersachsen und saß jetzt die letzten
viereinhalb Stunden in irgendwelchen
Regionalzügen aber ich mache das
natürlich so weiter weil ich will ja
auch nicht dass sie wieder meckert ich
habe eine Vermutung dass man von hier
aus einfach wieder nur zurückfahren kann
da wo ich gerade herkomme weil dieser
Zug fährt jetzt stumpf wieder zurück ich
musste dann eine Stunde warten bis der
Zug halt wiederk um dann wieder
zurückzufahren und habe erstmal was
gegessen bei mashis Grillstation sehr
sehr lecker kann ich empfehlen für alle
die halt unbedingt mal nach einbck
wollen gerade noch eine Kleinigkeit
gegessen es ist tatsächlich so dass es
hier in eins ach mann ey eins back zwei
back dreiback keine Ahnung nur ein
gleich gibt und es fährt die ganze Zeit
nur ein rb83 oder 86 von Götting nach
hier und dann irgendwann wieder zurück
und das heißt ich bin jetzt einfach
stumpf hier hingefahren und ich kann
halt auch nur diesen Zug wieder
zurücknehmen weil hier fährt halt kein
anderer hat sich gelohnt eine Stunde für
ein
Arsch ich glaube in genau demselben Zug
war ich vor einer Stunde auch schon
übgens mittlerweile jetzt auch schon 16
Uhr ich bin seit 10 Uhr unterwegs 6
Stunden ich denke so 10 werden es noch
so wieder in Götting ich bin jetzt
zumindest mal einem anderen Gleis und
zwar gleich hier kommt um 16:45 Uhr
einer von paderbornner aber der bleibt
glaub ich hier stehen dann fährt einer
um 17:9 Uhr noch bal Harzburg und hier
kommt um 17:4 Uhr einer der fährt nach Z
das wird mein nächster schauen wir mal
wo es liegt diger ich ich war noch in
keinem einzigen IC ich hatte kein
bordbist zu gar nichts ich will auch mal
ein Kaffee trinken oh das ist aber ganz
schön weit weg wo ist denn ulzen wow das
ist fast bei Hamburg ah hier steht's
also ich fahre jetzt gleich zweieinhalb
Stunden Regionalbahn stellt euch mal vor
am Ende des Tages war ich einfach nur in
Regionalzügen junge was ein Horror 16
Stunden am Stück Regionalbahn
[Musik]
fahren und TF ich weiß bescheid ich gehe
schon gucken irgendwas ist hier jetzt
gerade passiert auf jeden Fall fahre ich
jetzt schon wieder über dieses einstadt
nee auf jeden Fall da wo ich eben schon
war bin ich gerade lang gefahren gleich
geht die Sonne schon unter ich bin schon
so lange in
[Musik]
Regionalbahn nächster Halt Hannover
Hauptbahnhof Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung
links bitte vergessen Sie nicht Ihr
Gepäck danke hätte ich auch schon vor 8
Stunden sein können aber ich bin jetzt
erst hier weil Hannover ist nicht so
weit weg da bin ich mit Ice innerhalb
von einer Stunde oder so ihr könnt ja
gerne jetzt mal kommentieren was denkt
ihr wir haben jetzt 18:28 Uhr wann ist
Sense wann fährt kein Zug mehr und wo
muss ich dann bleiben ratet gerne mal in
den Kommentaren so Leute ich bin immer
noch im
RE2 nach ulzen mittlerweile ist es
draußen schon dunkel geworden glaube das
ist für mich persönlich K ich mache
dieses Video aber für mich persönlich
ist eigentlich der unnötigste Tag in
diesem Jahr den ich bis jetzt hatte weil
ich halt nur in Regionalzügen sitze und
das schon den ganzen Tag über aber
vielleicht passiert ja noch was
cooles so angekommen üzen habe ich vorer
auch noch nie gehört wie viele Leute
leben h eigentlich
34395 bin mittlerweile sogar auch nur
noch so 30 km von Hamburg Weg hier haben
wir jetzt das Gleis und mal gucken was
weitert es sieht schon mal echt gut aus
steht was von ICE jetzt muss ja nur noch
als nächstes kommen also auf diesem
Gleis haben wir ein IC um
20:42 Uhr auf dem Gleis wo ich gerade
angekommen bin ein RE 1 auch nach
Hamburg also komme ich heute auf jeden
Fall noch mit dem Regionalzug da nach
Hamburg aber halt immer noch Regionalzug
das kann doch nicht sein warum sind die
Gleise eigentlich 102 und 103 und nicht
eins und Z ich glaub die meisten Leute
die mich heute mit meiner Kamera hier
sehen denken auch irgendwie ich bin so
ein trainspotter oder so bin ich nicht
aber ich mag Züge zumindest wenn sie
pünktlich sind und heute waren
eigentlich alle
pünktlich
ich habe diese gelben Züge noch nie in
meinem Leben gesehen vorher ich bin
jetzt gerade auf jeden Fall in Lüneburg
dre viel Stunden sind wir da dann ist es
nach
ne okay Leute angekommen in Hamburg
erste Großstadt glaube ich heute und ich
bin tatsächlich also das muss man sich
auch mal geben ich bin nach Hamburg mit
Regionalbahn gefahren wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile zwar schon nach 21 Uhr und
ich bin jetzt 11 Stunden unterwegs also
11 Stunden nur Regionalbahn geil könnt
mir nichts besseres vorstellen das hätte
ich auch wirklich nicht gedacht also ich
war mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass
ich auch ICE fahren werde ich muss
eigentlich auch trinkend wieder was
essen ne wir haben jetzt hier gleich 14
und gleich 13 und mal schauen wo es
jetzt als nächstes hingeht weil ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass jetzt schon
Schluss ist ich gehe davon aus dass so
um 0 Uhr 0:30 Uhr ist dann
wahrscheinlich Schluss mit meinem
Experiment und ich bin dann irgendwo
gestrandet und musste halt pennen hier
links hatten wir wieder eine
Regionalbahn nach Lüneburg die ist
leider ausgefallen und auf dem rechten
Gleis hatten wir dann tatsächlich den
ersten IC nach Hamburg alten aber erst
in ein halben Stunde ich habe jetzt eine
halbe Stunde Aufenthalt hier das heißt
ich Gee mir erstmal was zu Essen holen
let's go Alter schaut mal der Food Court
hier in Hamburg sieht echt ziemlich geil
aus habe ich noch nie vorher gesehen und
das ist der günstigste ICE den ich je
Buche 4,55
okay ich fahre halt auch nur 12 Minuten
so Leute kürzeste it Fahrt meines Lebens
12 Minuten und dann sind wir in Hamburg
Altun dann ist es 22 Uhr und ich bin
mittlerweile echt ziemlich ko also so
langsam merke ich's so und dann sind wir
auch schon fertig mit IC gefahren und
steigen aus in Hamburg altuner ich bin
glaube ich der Einzige im Zug oder der
letzte gewesen so langsam werde ich auf
jeden Fall gespannt wie das jetzt noch
weitergeht weil ich könnte mir
eigentlich nur noch vorstellen dass
jetzt hier noch irgendwie andere Züge
wieder nach Hamburg fahren aber ob jetzt
um diese Uhrzeit noch wirklich viele
Züge in irgendeine andere Richtung
fahren magst du bezweifeln wobei es
eigentlich in Deutschland auch safe noch
weitergehen muss um diese Uhrzeit ich
weiß in Frankreich war glaube ich um 22
Uhr Schluss weil dann ist da so ein
Nachtfahrverbot und es fahren halt keine
Züge mehr auch kaum Nachtzüge wir gehen
mal zur Anzeigetafel ich befinde mich
übrigens auf Gleis 5 und da ist se und
hier kommt jetzt ein Zug an aus Basel
dann kommt noch einer an aus München und
noch einer aus München und okay aber die
fahren dann glaube ich auf jeden Fall
schon mal nicht mehr zurück und hier bin
ich gerade angekommen was steht da auch
den noch Ankunft ne hä lol also ich
hätte gedacht ein ICE fährt jetzt
irgendwo weiterhin weil ich bin jetzt ja
mittlerweile mal im ICE System oder
zumindest auf den ICE Gleis angekommen
leider ist ganz zum Schluss aber scheint
so als würde von diesen Gleisen kein Zug
mehr fahren und eigentlich haben wir
dann gesagt ist over ne na gut ich bin
jetzt halt auch 12 Stunden unterwegs ich
google mal kurz also da steht jetzt
bitte nicht einsteigen oben und das
steht da genauso und online steht es
fährt jetzt noch ein ICE von Hamburg
Altona nach Frankfurt allerdings braucht
er V hier aus un Stunden nach Frankfurt
und der fährt auch von Gleis neun also
von dem anderen Gleis deswegen bin ich
auf der einen Seite froh dass ich jetzt
hier bin auf der anderen Seite hätte ich
gedacht wirklich dass es noch weitergeht
aber die Challenge ist over ich habe
meine Gesamtstrecke mal
zusammengerechnet und bin etwas
überrascht ich bin einfach nur 581 km an
diesem Tag mit Zügen Gefahren klar halt
eigentlich nur in Regionalzügen aber ich
hätte wirklich gedacht dass wird
deutlich deutlich mehr da hätte ich auch
fast wieder mit meinem e-back fahren
können so Leute ich habe mir ein
e-coooter geschnappt und bin jetzt
gerade auf dem Weg zum Hotel ja ich habe
mich gerade schon Verfahren und bin
einfach zum falschen Hotel gefahren weil
meine Konzentration so langsam nachlässt
aber wir haben es jetzt geschafft
Abfahrt einfach so eine unnötige
E-Scooter Route 6 km und ich war erst
hier oben und war halt komplett falsch
und muss jetzt hierhin und das Beste ist
wenn man den E-Scooter dann nicht mehr
vom Hotel parken kann weil er so eine
nonpking Zone ist jetzt muss ich 500 m
zurückrennen ey wirklich hier hinter ist
übrigens der Fernsehturm von Hamburg und
der leuchtet gerade so mit HSV fahren
also vom Fußballverein so und jetzt
geht's ab ins Hotel ich habe übrigens
heute den ganzen Tag mit der GoPro
gefilmt weil ich muss sagen die Qualität
gefällt mir echt gut und die hat man
halt immer so schnell griffbereit wird
natürlich kein Standard aber heute hat's
echt irgendwie geholfen und war super
praktisch gebucht habe ich mir für heute
noch mal das möwenpick Hotel Hamburg
eigentlich dachte ich die machen nur Eis
aber die haben auch ein Hotel
anscheinend mein Zimmer ist einfach am
14 Stock ich glaub das ist recht
hoch oh das sieht do gut aus und man
kann sogar auf den ich dachte jetzt ich
kann vielleicht auf den Hafen gucken
aber sieht auch ganz gut aus Leute
endlich da wenn ich noch was mache seht
ihr das jetzt sonst war das und wir
sehen uns morgen früh wieder ich weiß es
noch ich muss mal abchecken was hier
noch jetzt so geht Leute guten Morgen
gerade Haare noch nass ich habe
wunderbar geschlafen hier in Hamburg
schaut euch mal diesen phänomenalen
Ausblick an aus meinem Hotelzimmer ich
muss leider sagen gestern ging nichts
mehr ich meine Hamburg habe ich auch
schon zich mal gesehen wenn ich jetzt in
irgendeiner anderen Stadt gewesen wäre
wo ich noch nie war dann hätte ich
natürlich safe die Motivation gehabt ich
muss h noch irgendwas sehen aber ich
habe paar Bekannte gefragt ob die mit
mir noch was machen wollen und irgendwie
war keiner dabei und ich wollte dann
auch nicht alleine irgendwo hingehen ich
hoffe das könnt ihr verstehen dass ich
in dem Video dann eigentlich
ausschließlich nur Zug gefahren bin
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen l gerne Daumen nach
oben da weitere Ideen für weitere solche
Videos schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder
da gibt's auch ein richtig geiles Video
haut rein Leute ciao